this episode of the honeydew is brought
to you by ritual green chef
and keeps more on that later let's get
into the do
the honeydew with ryan zickler
welcome back to the honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
studios i am ryan sickler
ryan sickler.com ryan sickler on all
social media
every episode i'm gonna tell you how
much i appreciate you guys this
community continues to grow
please subscribe to the youtube channel
you're getting audio on mondays
video on tuesdays and if you need
another episode a week
please sign up to the patreon uh that is
has become such a wild show i i i say it
once we cast that line out to y'all yeah
i'm not disappointed in your uh
low lights out there so if you or
someone you know has that story that has
to be heard
please submit the honeydew podcast to
gmail.com
uh the patreon is five bucks a month
that's it i think for the year if you
sign up for a year it's like 54 bucks
and you get like over a month of free
episodes so if you're in
do that you'll save on some money all
right um look you guys know i record
here at the santa monica music center
i'm really proud of a
program we're doing right now it's a
non-profit for some at-risk youth
we're working with the santa monica
police department it's called outreach
through the arts
we're bringing kids in the studio here
to teach them about podcasting
editing cameras in front of the mic
behind the scenes you know doing what
ash does doing what i do
giving them a curriculum and a course so
they can go out and get these jobs where
they don't have to work at little
caesars for minimum wage and there's
nothing wrong with that i'm just saying
college may not be for everybody so
we're doing a give back program
i'll be telling you more about that as
we keep going but they're having a hell
of a time right now
and i'm just really proud of it so it's
something i'm going to promote and
get these kids some exposure um that's
the
the biz y'all uh you know what we do
here we highlight the low lights these
are the stories behind the storytellers
i'm very excited to have this guest
here today uh honeydew getting big time
names right now
first time here on the dew ladies and
gentlemen please welcome bassem youssef
all right oh thank you so much oh my god
thank you i feel the love
if you live listen i said before i've
been mesmerized by your eyes over here
bro
i get eye compliments man you're just uh
i'm as straight as they come but man
you're
you're melting me bro you're melting
how are you today i'm good i'm good
thank you i'm so glad to have you here
uh before we dive into any of this
please plug
promote everything and anything you'd
like okay
right now yeah right now oh okay i'm uh
i'm touring i'm doing stand-up comedy
everywhere uh
and i have a new book a children's book
called
the magical reality of nadia and uh
i if i'm coming to your town which i
will
announce soon please come to my show it
is interesting and it is part of my
story
are you touring internationally as well
or just in the states
right now i'm touring the states so i've
been to uh dallas
tampa that's during the pandemic
yeah new jersey
then uh houston uh i win in timonium
maryland and in two weeks i'm going to
be in ohio
and in the qahoga falls and then miami
have you done any um overseas shows
since the pandemic started not since the
pandemonium was just curious
i did london but that's before the
pandemic okay yeah
so i um i researched you i looked you up
i i
you know i wikipedia so who knows how
much of that shit's real but you're the
[ __ ] real deal obviously i've i've
heard about you have known about you but
i didn't know
all the [ __ ] that comes with you like
you're
how do you say it cardiothoracic than a
character a heart surgeon you were a
heart surgeon laymen terminology heart
surgery
i mean you were literally a heart
surgeon yes who shifted gears into
comedy yes
by accident you're telling me or
absolutely absolutely by accident
and then at what age uh 39 39
and you're now 47 so eight years in
you're a [ __ ]
heart surgeon you got a children's book
you're a successful comedian you're a
uh you're famous in in how many goddamn
countries i'm also vegan
and you're vegan i mean just go [ __ ]
yourself and then do the show about it
so can we you know what we do here i say
we highlight the low lights let's start
with
um you know where you're from originally
how you get into
medicine and then we can take it from
there all right
so uh kind of the uh
the quick version of it uh a very
traditional
upbringing in egypt uh went to medical
school
uh became a heart surgeon did that for
12 years after medical school
what age are you a heart surgeon um 25
20 yeah so let me get can 25 ask you a
few questions about that
craziest thing how many surgeries would
you say you've performed oh i can't even
remember 12 years ago we're talking
about thousands
i mean hundreds yeah because you see in
heart surgery you first assist you
assist a lot
okay until you do your own okay but how
many of your own would you say
are we i i would say in the hundreds
yeah okay what's your
success rate oh thank god it's like 98
percent
is it really yeah yeah so you've only
lost a cup yeah yeah
that's damn good 98 percent you're who i
want to [ __ ] see
i don't care if we're on the road and i
have a heart attack but let me look at
it
so 98 what's the craziest one you've
ever
what's the craziest no the crazy stuff
doesn't happen in the operation room in
the heart surgery because he
most most of the time people that come
to the heart
it's kind of they're being prepared to
the uh
to the operation it's the emergencies
you know you had the emergency oh yeah
yeah gunshots
uh oh so you're not just doing health
and everything you're doing
if someone gets shot in the heart you're
working on that too yeah yeah that's
heart surgery
all of it because there's a difference
between a cardiologist and a heart
surgeon
a cardiologist he's just like he's an
interventional that's what okay but the
heart surgery
actually cracks up your chest so what's
the craziest stuff then a gun shot
yeah we had we had a gunshot and i had
to uh and they and i was the
house surgeon in in on coal uh
and uh i mean the guy who came in
dead and uh the thing is his parents
were out there and this it's i think
there was some sort of uh
it was a two families fighting each
other from rural egypt and
they're with and the family waiting
outside and and of course
they were already angry so it's kind of
we are the weakest link as doctors
so you're the don't kill the messenger
and you're the [ __ ] message
yeah and he already that there is like
his dad and
he was like what what the hell are you
going to do there is nothing and they
were waiting for us outside
and uh and then it was leaked that the
their relative was dead and so they
started to
kind of destroy the emergency oh man so
we had to escape from the back door
but that happens a lot a lot oh yeah
yeah that's that's part of that's
that is that is like every single intern
resident story in in an egyptian
hospital do all the heart surgeons wear
[ __ ] sneakers and [ __ ]
you're running the [ __ ] out of the lake
if you're just a doctor you don't want
to wear those dresses no no sometimes we
just like you take off our like your
scrubs and then just like walk out
do like do like a kaiser sozi thing
stop limping on the way out yeah yeah
um have you ever i'm
guessing you have have you had to be the
person to go tell family members oh yeah
many times i mean what is that like
yeah it is uh how do you how do you i
mean i do this will sound terrible
but it becomes part of your life part of
your routine you're not phased out
anymore you just like
yeah on to the next patient right on to
the next case
i i this is this is the worst thing that
happens for you when you go
your your medical profession it just
they turn to cases
i remember um when my father died i was
16 and i went to my doctor
and he said to me because he knew my dad
and he goes listen
and it was so it was such a human moment
because i i up to then i'm 16 i looked
at this guy like he's a doctor he must
know everything you know what i mean
and he said look i want to tell you they
teach us in medical medical school how
to deal with these things but they don't
teach you
what to say about that to someone
especially a kid so i don't even know
what to [ __ ] say to you i'm really
sorry and i was like damn that was the
first time i realized like
you know doctors are people too like you
know you remember i don't know if this
ever happened to you but
i remember being in like elementary
school maybe fifth grade and seeing my
teacher out
at the mall or something i was like oh
my god you're a real person yeah you
know what i mean
like i just usually see you in this
square room and you're teaching me this
one [ __ ] thing
so i thought that was a really cool
moment but i get it i mean obviously if
you're doing hundreds of them it's like
yeah he's dead well actually the
projection that you just said about like
how you project other people
that's the kind of that could be the
story of my life and it even
it was even augmented when i became a
satirist that's even worse
you're not just speaking to one person
because of his parents you're speaking
to 40 million people that's how many
people are watching the show
and when you have so many people
watching you that's dangerous
because 40 million people have an
opinion about you and it's uh
that was kind of like part of the stress
and the pressure that i was always under
for the eight nine years that uh that
i've been into
the medium so what was the shift
what happened were you not happy being
uh
you say it was an accident so let's hear
how i was never happy being a doctor
never never was it something your family
wanted you to do was that a family
practice
not a family practice no but that's i
make this joke all the time i say
in the middle east you're expected to be
one of three things a doctor an engineer
or a disappointment
so that is that's the expectations
and uh and and it doesn't matter how
many times just like you know it's there
and it's just like imposed on you
somehow they
parents they will never say oh we need
we never forced you
you you got it by yourself but it's kind
of like what did your parents do
my father was a judge and my mom was a
uh uh
um a business uh professor a judge what
kind of judge
uh supreme court supreme court judge
holy
crap yeah so uh they were like you know
middle class
very respected people but it is that
part of the picture has to the picture
have to be complete the social picture
so my older brother became an engineer
so
one more slot for me i became a doctor
thank god we didn't have a third
uh child the third brother he would be
at this point
so we kind of like so somebody had to
take that so i became the disappointment
no just kidding so i was gonna say yeah
i mean what happens when you shift do
they
no no it i think it's like the whole
country shifted
uh i i but by by 2011
i was already on my way to come to
america
because i passed all of my american
exams my usmles and i had already
a fellowship waiting for me here in
america where
cleveland okay so i was going there
and then the revolution happened the
arab spring
what year is this 2011 yeah 2011. so
2011 happened
and um i
i was part of the doctors that went to
tahrir square to you know fix people's
injuries you know there was like a lot
of clashes and people getting
shot and killed and we just left
everything and we went there
and when you are on the ground you
realize that there are two different
type of realities the reality that you
know for sure that you see for yourself
people wanting change good people
wanting a revolution wanting democracy
and then there is the other reality that
is propagated by the state-run media
which is a conspiracy these are like you
know insurgents
and i all my life i was mesmerized by
john stewart
he was the reason why i understood
even not political satire politics in in
america i'm not kidding you
i'm with you on that i got i truly
believe i got
more informative better news from jon
stewart than
cnn any of these places any of them jon
stewart was and to come from
mtv yeah to come up through mtv
and parlay that into you know the daily
show and everything else
just amazing he's the man all the work
he does with the firemen in 911
and all that he's great and in 2001 i
that was the first time i saw him on
television i was visiting america
and you had never heard of him or seen
him prior to that no we have 1990s like
how would you know and uh and then
i started to watch the show
and i couldn't understand it because i
didn't know who are democrats what are
republicans what is fox news
so i he educated me about that so
always like in the back of my mind can
we ever have a show like this but
it's wishful thinking because we were
living under dictatorship then we have a
revolution
and then suddenly there is like a space
an opportunity
so i started these youtube videos okay
so are you saying prior to
the revolution you weren't allowed to do
youtube chat no shows like that at all
no no you couldn't
do anything that is related to politics
at all
that you you'll be picked up you know to
silicon a dictatorship that's been there
for 30 years it's kind of like
an a a better dictionary dictatorship
than we have now
but at that time still a dictatorship so
so they would come get you if you did
some [ __ ] like yeah
so we had a revolution then there is a
space on opportunity so i did the
youtube videos and i didn't think about
about this going anywhere i was going to
cleveland you know
next thing i know millions of views
millions five million views in a few
weeks and i know that i understand
and i know that now you get five million
views when your dog farts on tick tock
but at that time five million views 2011
in egypt that was a huge deal that like
no other videos actually these
these kind of numbers suddenly every
everybody stops me in the street
suddenly everybody knows me suddenly i'm
in the morning grounds with my doctors
with my professors and patients are
recognizing me
and it was funny because the patient was
like ah here's the funny guy from the
internet
see is he going to operate on me please
yeah that would be that too it's kind of
like oh this guy's like parker is like a
startup truck it's like now i don't want
this guy to crack my chest open please
like can somebody else take this i don't
want to i don't want to be part of this
you know
love your show you ain't working on me
though man so
so that that was a little bit
embarrassing but i continued being a
doctor
and like i i continued being a doctor by
doing the youtube videos
did it had end up conflicting no but i
did i
ended up having offers from television
and now i have to ch to ch and and the
same week that i got my uh
my my tv deal the papers from cleveland
finally arrived and now i have to make a
choice
so they or comedy bro it's comedy you
did the right
no i didn't no it was cleveland or money
so i chose the money
because it was like decent money it was
tv money
yeah so i did i did the show so you get
your own what like daily show
weekly weekly show in egypt yeah and
uh again and then it exploded 40 million
people watching the show 40 million
people watching every episode
these are numbers never seen before and
now with the rise of the show there's a
rise of the islamists the islamists came
to the
power too so they didn't like what i
have to say about it so
are you getting death threats are you
yeah but you see when
here's the thing when death threats when
people that kind of liked
i i said guys did somebody send me
emails and you and comments and i
thought like i'm going to kill you
a million times that's why i went in i
got death threats really did you have
somebody coming up your house
and with the knife no it's a comment on
youtube it's like [ __ ] you got this the
whole time
you got an email then she said what the
[ __ ] like
seriously you know celebrity these days
it's like oh i've got a bullet
that's right all right imagine if you're
having a 40 million people and half of
them like hate watch your show yeah
and and and kind of and the government
is against you and you have militias
coming up and having your your pictures
being burned you know so it's like [ __ ]
you it's like yeah
when people's like were you threatened
like yeah but i didn't think about it i
had a show to do you know
i was actually more more worried about
being
slaughtered in twitter if i have a bad
episode
yes because if you have so if you have a
death threat what's the worst that you
can happen
you're gonna die yeah and you're gonna
die like a hero and that's it and you
don't have to worry about the
preparation of the next show again but
if you have a bad show
you have no excuse he's like oh my god
i'm sorry i had death threats so i
didn't write good jokes nobody
cares you are a commodity you are a
commodity
you're being thrown to the lines and you
have to perform no matter what
so i became this you know guy who does
the show
and i woke up one day and i have there's
a warrant for my arrest from the
islamists so i went there and i was
interrogated for six hours
why is there a war what uh i was accused
of four accounts insulting the president
insulting islam
spreading false rumors and disrupting
the fabric of society whatever the [ __ ]
that means and then
no where is there you're taken there do
they come get you or you go
uh so the warrant was against me and i
turned myself into the general
prosecutor kind of like the d.a here
okay
and uh you're sitting with this yeah and
for six hours they're asking me to
explain my jokes
i know i know i know it's crazy they're
asking me
they're asking me and it's crazy it's
like what did you mean by this joke so i
said nothing so why did the people left
was like guys are you kidding me
and it was like it was like for six
hours and they tried to even play the
episodes but they were playing it on a
very outdated computer so
it was not working so they ended up
having transcripts reading joked by joke
and the worst part about it is that as
they were reading my jokes
i i was thinking myself damn these jokes
are not that funny so i
i need new right i know yeah i did so
like i went out to bid and i
and i fired half of my staff
i know i know that's what you thought
the crime was
the the whole i don't know if they were
really asking me if i'm
breaking the law or because they're not
funny enough yeah and it was crazy i
mean like there was like a whole like
i was being arrested and this was
broadcasted on cnn which is like
the the the happiest your arrest was uh
it was broadcasted on cnn so i was going
there and then there was like a lot of
like i was surrounded by policemen then
they put me in
and then the policemen the police
officers
as they were putting me into they asked
me for selfies for their kids because it
was a possibility
but they did yeah it's like ah doctors
like it's like why don't you smile it's
like why don't why
why do you think i'm not smiling because
everyone will call you doctors still
yeah okay i'm a doctor yeah you are like
they're still
comedy and getting rid of that yeah so
yeah and so i took
pictures with the police officers and uh
i posed a few times to give him the
smile that he wants for his kid
and then after the military after the
islamists
uh you know after that by two months the
military came in and they removed the
islamists now the mill
at that time i was a national hero i was
the one who stood against the islams
right
in the middle hold on we can't gloss
over
national hero what does that feel like
does it feel like anything do you seem
like a very humble grounded man that
doesn't get too
too hyped up on your own [ __ ] but
yeah because
that's because i think part of it is
that i became famous very late
and i became famous after being a doctor
and being really being like you know
kind of having a very tough life as a
resident so we're not used to
we're not used to praise we used to be
basically
pounded on by our professors and uh
so this all this whole thing about like
fame and being you know
that that much exposure i'm not used to
so what's it like going out in public at
this point
oh it's torture i couldn't uh i mean
it's it's it's great and everything but
you
you couldn't you couldn't have like so
it's kind of like you cave in the uk you
kind of
you avoid public places but then i
uh like i was like oh he's the one who
stood against them a muslim brotherhood
he's the one who won an islamist and
again that was a projection that i never
asked for because i never
i always said this is not an activist
show
this is a comedy show we don't care
about
your political um projection about me
because i am not
so uh now the
military are in power and i'm an equal
opportunity offender i don't care who's
in power i make fun who's in the program
so i made one episode about the military
and i was canceled after one perhaps no
way
yeah and then i don't wanna they got
they're that fast
oh oh no no and and families and friends
turned against me because if you think
that in egypt if you think the
religion is is holy military military is
sacred
you can't even touch it more than
religion 100 whoa
i didn't know that yeah yeah so um and
uh the military was just like it's it's
it's they're untouchable what do you
remember your joke
no i it was not even the joke it was
basically it was joking about the
propaganda of the military i see
i i never so it wasn't even really a
joke the thing is like i never made fun
of religion and i didn't make fun of the
military i made fun of the people who
represent both
who like to hide i always say small
people hide behind big ideas
so small people right behind the flag
patriotism
religion allah jesus
and they kind of like and so if you make
fun of me you make fun of all of these
things that i'm hiding behind
which is of course very well said yeah
[ __ ] so
uh i i made fun about all their
propaganda and so
i i was canceled um people my friends
and family
many of them turned against me even
really even my mom your mom
yeah and that wow that's harsh
no no seriously my mom but that was even
so
after the military came in there was
like a it was like uh
martial laws and there was like people
killed in the streets and it was
terrible
so the show suspended before we come
back on air because there were martial
laws
how many episodes in are you at this
point uh that point
i know uh two years ago wow but that
but now there is the military is now
kind of showing signs of military
fascism after religious version so i
started to write against it
before my show is on the air again my
mom is not happy so now the military is
the only one can save us you cannot say
this about the military and she was very
angry at me
and for 10 days we do not speak and is
that a long time normally for you guys
yeah because my mom is a typical mom
that she always expect
us to uh apologize so this time i didn't
she's this one a very very proud woman
and on the 11th day so on the 10th day
we talk
small talk i called her okay
uh i didn't speak i i we i we didn't
speak about what happened but like it
was all
we feel there's attention on the call
the next day she died
no yeah yeah so she went in
she went to sleep and she never woke up
my dad called me the next day your mom
died
how old was she no she was like she was
64. 64.
absolutely healthy yeah so
uh and so after that so after that
after that i do my show and that is the
one episode after which everybody turned
against me and i turned from
and now i'm thankful that my mom didn't
get to see that
because she didn't see the turn against
me so kind of
that's the first blessing in disguise
now can i can i
just ask you a few questions here about
your mom's passion were you very close
to your mom yeah absolutely
and i mean how glad you that you called
you make you wait one more day and you
don't talk to her ever again the way you
go out is on an argument
well i am glad but like i if that didn't
happen i mean
i don't i don't want to beat myself up
to that because
i didn't kill her you know and maybe if
we i continued to do the show and then
she saw
the stuff that's happening to me and the
turn and something happened maybe i
would have felt guilty but
you know it it happened and so she died
very peacefully
in her sleep and then i did the and then
i continued doing the show and then this
one episode and then everybody turns
against me now i'm the most hated person
in egypt
by the propaganda right many people
still like me but they are afraid to
speak up now
i i stay unemployed for four months i go
to another network a regional network
and i go in for another run a few months
and then i get cancelled again
and now there is it's becoming
more and more difficult
to stay in egypt and now there is a
court cases against me all of these fake
stuff that actually make me make you
kind of like put you in jail but without
using the whole idea about freedom of
expression you know taxes whatever then
then i had a verdict against me finding
me 100 million pounds
out of nowhere the lawyer said you need
to leave egypt i leave egypt
i never come back i leave egypt in 10th
of november
uh 2014 i leave i go to dubai
three months later my father died in a
car accident now
both of my parents died but here's the
blessing in disguise both of my parents
died suddenly
my mom died in her sleep my dad he died
in a car accident
they did not suffer they died instantly
it's devastating they are taken away
from you
but now i saw both of my grandparents
from both sides
dying very slow humiliating death
dementia
diapers alzheimer's
the works my grandmother from my
mother's side i was in bed for 10 years
and she was like she couldn't understand
and you know when you said like oh i
hope she's just like she rests
i was always in fear of seeing my dad
and my mom
going through this so when they died
only half of them
are members of very strong independent
people and they didn't
and now that i'm uprooted from my own
country i'm in america i don't have to
worry about them anymore
so that's why i tell you it's a it is a
tragedy but it's a blessing
in disguise a big big big pla like a
blessing in this guy so
now it comes to the trauma the big
trauma now the big trauma is not the
death the big trauma is like how you're
approach
uprooted and everything that you worked
for
and we did i did a show that it was
never done in the history of the airport
40 million people watching me were there
other copycat shows
after you started all failed yeah and
then
i have nothing ever like you know
i'm a husband now and in the span of
what are we taught three years
four years four years yeah and now i i
the only
way that i would could stay in the
middle east is i had to compromise
the military intelligence would send
people to me come back and do the show
but we're going to be at some sort of an
understanding
here take a game do a game show do so
you know
do something that is not related to
politics speak to do like
celebrities dudes like jimmy fallon kind
of thing don't do
politics don't do you yeah and i left
everything
and i came to america have you been here
before for
any any reason america yeah oh i visited
america
okay i always visit america i mean i
always like being in america and
so i come here and i have nothing and
now this is where the trump where do you
go first
uh oakland and then oakland yeah where'd
you pick up
we had we had friends there that kind of
we stayed because we didn't we needed to
ground ourselves from egypt to oakland
huh yeah that's tight
then i leave i like that dude i know
and uh and i leave that and i come to
los angeles
now i'm i'm someone who's huge in the
middle east but doesn't matter here you
know ain't nobody here
now we have to build your career from
the ground up again
and the
the amount the the difficulty is not
just trying to make it here but also
having to deal with your fans who always
follow you and consider you as a failure
because you cannot do the show anymore
and so why don't you do the show from
youtube i was just like why it's no
point anymore
and then i started to try to build
my name here very slowly so i started to
give
lectures talks then i took this lecture
and talks and i turned them into
stand-up
okay so your lectures and talks on what
are you back to cardio
no no no no like talks about my
experience no no no i'm
i'm done with medicine god and i mean i
i stay that way yeah i i make this joke
like i'm not a doctor anymore and
because of that many more patients are
alive today
so so i'm here i'm here and now
i start doing stand-up let's take a
quick break and tell you about our first
sponsor ritual we deserve to know what
we're putting in our bodies
and why especially when it comes to
something we take every day
rituals clean vegan-friendly
multivitamin is formulated with high
quality nutrients and bio-available
forms
your body can actually use you won't
find sugars
gmos major allergens synthetic fillers
and artificial colorants plus
the fresh taste and the laid release
capsule design makes taking your
vitamins
easy i take ritual every day i just got
my monthly shipment again the other day
i'm actually buying them
i really like them for for years i've
been looking for a daily vitamin it
didn't have all the fillers and
everything in it
and ritual's been fantastic and it does
have a really clean
refreshing taste that you actually
doesn't you know when you take stuff and
it gets stuck back in your throat you're
like
and then you get it down you taste that
all day not with ritual
all right ritual is designed with you in
mind and it's now available for women
men
and teens ritual multivitamins are
scientifically developed to help support
different life stages ritual makes
healthy habits easy
your multivitamins are delivered to your
door every month with free shipping
always you can start snooze or cancel
your subscription
anytime and if you don't love ritual
within your first month
they'll refund your first order get key
nutrients without the bs
alright ritual is offering my listeners
10 off during your first three months so
visit
ritual.com honeydew to start your ritual
today
our next sponsor is green chef green
chef is the first usda certified organic
meal kit company you can enjoy clean
ingredients that you can trust
seasonally sourced for peak freshness
green chef
is the most sustainable meal kit
offsetting 100 of its direct carbon
emissions
and plastic packaging in every box so
you can feel great
about what you're eating and how it got
to your table
ingredients come pre-measured perfectly
portioned and mostly prepped so you can
spend less time stressing
and more time enjoying delicious
home-cooked meals green chef makes
eating well
easy and affordable with plans to fit
every lifestyle so whether you're
your keto your paleo your vegan your
vegetarian or if you're just looking to
eat healthier like me
there's a range of recipes to suit any
diet or preference look i've
i know all the paleos and the ketos and
the this is into that they don't work
for me because i can't stick with it
long enough that's just the truth i'll
get weak i'll eat pizza
i'll go out and have tacos whatever it
is uh but with green chef they
they definitely send you this stuff
portioned out it's easy to make i'm not
spending all night in the kitchen
you know make a handful of meals
throughout the week and take care of
yourself you feel
so much better in the end go to
greenchef.com
90 honeydew and use code 90 honeydew
that's nine
zero honeydew to get ninety dollars off
including free shipping
that's ninety dollars off including free
shipping when you go to green chef dot
com slash
90 honeydew and use code 90 honeydew at
checkout green chef the number one meal
kit
for eating well our next sponsor is
keeps did you know
two out of three men will experience
some form of hair loss
by the time they are 35 keeps offers a
simple stress-free way to keep your hair
low-cost treatments start at just 10 a
month and
keeps offers generic versions there's
convenient virtual doctor consultations
and medications delivered straight to
your door
every three months you do not have to
even leave your home they have discreet
packaging and proven results
keeps has more five-star reviews than
any of its competitors all right
treatments can take four to six months
to see results so act fast
you know keeps keeps coming back because
you all keep using them
and they're a great company plenty of
people here at the studio are using them
i got friends using keeps right now
i know dudes back in the day in my high
school and college days that would love
to have something like keeps to keep
that hair because they are bald
all right so if you are ready to take
action and prevent hair loss
go to k-e-e-p-s dot com slash
honeydew to receive your first month of
treatment for free that's k-e-e-p-s
dot com slash honeydew to receive your
first month free
k-e-e-p-s dot com slash honeydew
now let's get back to the do where's the
first place you went
uh certain place in los angeles uh
new york and it was terrible
english is my second language and it's
not just the language
it's not just the jokes it's the
delivery it's rewiring your brain for
the right cadence the right speed
the right rhythm i have to re-learn how
to speak
yeah you got to be a whole different
person yeah i mean you've had to learn
how to be
in a yeah that's crazy i couldn't
imagine that going to another country
and then being like oh man i've been
doing it this way all this time
yeah so i managed to get a residency in
joe's pub in new york
stayed there for two months some days
some nights were better than the others
some nights were terrible other nights
were okay
and then after two years i now have like
a tour
and i'm going and i'm doing it in in in
mixed rooms between arabs and americans
and i am pitching
shows for hbo and waiting for the
results and i'm pitching
and now i have a children's show that's
doing very well and i have
um an animation studio that wants to
take this
book to turn it into an animation series
so
i'm still getting around here and
i'm the age of 47 and i'm doing stuff
that
young 22 years comedians do but i'm
happy
because it is very scary very
unsettling i'm learning something
every day uh um
some some days i will be in a theater
like the kennedy center with 2000 seats
watching the show
and some that time i will be in timonium
maryland
doing the show for 18 people
and i would tell you the smaller rooms
are a blessing
because they teach you stuff that they
cannot that kind of that you cannot
learn
from the bigger rooms and it's my
it's i i think that the one thing that i
was struggling with
is the whole idea of am i good enough
am i talented enough was that a fluke
was it just like all
luck and i'm not really that good and
that kind of like self-doubt that kind
of
always the impostor syndrome everybody
has it
and i'm still asking these questions
every day and i'm still always doing it
every day so but at least
i think it keeps you in check you know
it really humbles you and keeps you
grounded and keeps yourself
in check yeah so a lot of people look at
the
the first transformation between a
doctor and a medical
and and and a comedian i said like oh
that's huge but i would think that the
the second reinvention i i agree was
even
much more difficult because you're
coming here i've never been a doctor and
i would agree with that yeah
yeah the second reinvention going from
doctor to comedian would be easier than
going from
someone who's so big in egypt to no one
in america
and trying to do it and then restarting
not just restarting but
reef refining yourself you're refining
yourself
and until today you have egyptians big
fans come to the shows like why don't
you do it in eric so even your
your some of your fans not even
accepting that
if they if you're not doing the show
you're not relevant
and i discovered that those people are
just locking themselves into not just in
the
in the show they're locking themselves
into that era
the two three years when we had hope
because that is kind of more nostalgic
it's not about the show but what it
represented
and i had a third degree invention so in
the middle i
i in the middle of all of this i turned
plant-based diet vegan right
wait let me ask you before we get in the
vehicle because that's that's actually
like
a third intervention there's not just
like i'm not i i say i'm arab
and vegan which makes me scary and
annoying but
but i i promise you it's this is not
gonna be an annoying story
i believe you i just want to know have
you gone back and done
any stand-up or anything anywhere close
to home
uh in jordan in lebanon how was it
it was good yeah yeah you have a good
turnout
people really go yeah but they're still
coming in expecting
uh the show yeah they are huh yeah not
stand up yeah okay so we
we go to so what makes you do that 2013
i became plant-based diet because a
friend of mine had ms and he kind of
reversed his disease so i
really did yeah so for me i turned i
switched to plant-based diet not
not because of like you know not for
ethical reasons which i do respect that
when people do it but it's more of
health reasons so i'm not militant
i would cheat every now and then it's
fine what does a cheat meal for it's
like a little bit of cheese you know
like a pizza whatever you know so
um then i started to speak about that
and then people ridiculed me like oh
this because you cannot speak about
politics you're speaking about food
why don't you go back and make me a
sandwich
you know you gotta love the [ __ ] yeah
yeah so suddenly i'm a woman now yeah so
so
so that made me angry so i
said i'm gonna make the one thing that
people make fun of the most successful
thing that i do
so i created a website it's called plan
b
tv it's the only bilingual website in
the world of a plant-based diet it has
videos it has recipes it has success
stories that's articles everything
what's the website again plant bee plant
plant v that's what i wanted to make
sure right not tv not plan b
yeah and it's and it and it's and it's
and it's meant to be because
i tell people if you're eating your
steaks and chicken and happy
do good for you but if you have a
problem try
try plan b trap plants so that's that's
how we do
so and then i managed to take the that
the video the online video
and i sold a show to a tv network in the
middle east about plant-based night so i
did the same thing when i did with
the political satire show took it from
the internet and did a whole show
and i sold and now i'm negotiating even
a bigger deal with a bigger net network
really
to do a reality tv show about
transformation about getting people it's
kind of like the biggest loser but
instead of losing
pounds and weight you're losing
medications only through plan based diet
yeah okay so i'm doing that and then i
and i'm now turning plant b into
an app where people are gonna have like
a paid subscription in order to have
medical coaching medical consultation
and so i'm bringing
investors or you're brought in an
investor so
you're a [ __ ] juggernaut so so so
it's kind of now it's kind of like i was
because i was pissed because how people
would okay
can we stop for a second you we cannot
gloss over your friend had ms and
reversed his effects this is
that's major what how what
plant-based diet and what do you what
changes do you see is it gone
or is it minimalized what are we talking
about no it's totally under control so
he
used to have like five uh symptoms uh
you know his ear
there's some stuff that are reversible
so his left ear is like 20
gone but he had like uh tingling like
you know
paris's pain and that's all gone now and
he's now playing water polo again
and he has these retreats would people
come in for water fasting so he did it
by two things water fasting and
refeeding on plant-based diet
so as a doctor i was one of those people
who made fun of vegans all the time
but now i started to read about it and
basically it's about
reducing inflammation here in california
you have
lumalinda loma linda is one of the blue
zones and the reason why it's
called a blue zone yeah there's like
five blue zones around the world
okay what's the blues are a blue zone
where
you have uh uh the population of that
region
have much longer life expert expectancy
expectancy
and much less chronic diseases and where
is that low melinda where else around
melinda is the only one in america there
is okinawa in japan there is
so one in italy there is one in um
uh i forgot the last two there i think
there's one
costa rica and there's one more so
and then they found that these people
have a a much more plant-based diet
based
food and if they eat fish or meat
they're like in very very very small
amounts
so fish in small amounts yeah okay fish
or even meat in small amounts very very
small amounts
so um there is there's a lot there's a
lot of science there's a lot of papers
and it's much more researched than any
other of those like keto or paleo diets
so uh i i i i watched documentaries i
i attended their conferences and i got
sold and said this is the way to do
and again this is not like about it's
not militant
i even tell people it's not it's what
you do 90
80 of your life if you want to you know
cheat
every now and then that's fine but if
you have a chronic disease i recommend
that you go more 100
so now i'm changing people's minds
through food
and now i have more followers and
they're now there people are meeting me
in
in the middle east it's like i didn't
know that you had a comedy show
i knew you from the plan b show so
[ __ ] yeah so how long have you been
plant-based
uh seven years seven years yeah and what
what do you notice differently about
yourself because you said you used to
make fun of the vegans so what how much
different well first of all my my eyes
were brown now they're blue
because that's the first thing you said
no uh i feel much more healthier i'm
much more
rested i have less inflammation joints
feel better yeah
my recovery time is much better i mean
there is like one of the best
show of movies documentaries the game
changers
it's incredible it's about vegan
athletes
and that's called the game change the
game changes all the game changes
yeah and and now you have people who are
like elite athletes who are on
plant-based diet it's great yeah
so when i do it i don't do it in a way
kind of like to change people's
lifestyle i said like if you're happy
with your lifestyle whatever meat and
chicken you're eating that's fine but
you have
chronic problems if you have a problem
with your sleeping with your energy
maybe you would like to try something
else and and a lot of people try it
maybe
i do even have a 21 days challenge
people do it and they feel amazing
and then they come back and they eat a
little bit of meat but not as much as
they
used to so they kind of change their
mind so
kind of like my whole life now is kind
of like reinvention and trying to
challenge yourselves and putting
yourself in
in places where you're not very
comfortable i'm a big believer
in getting yourself out of your comfort
zone i'm a big believer in
change a change is a pain in the ass but
it is so necessary yeah
it is so necessary every time change has
been
even forced upon me i've uh been able to
adapt and move on and then look back and
be like
thank god this happened thank god this
happened yeah so
has that um it's been thrown at you your
whole life like that it sounds like
well wait up you we did talk about
before you got on you said you had no
troub you had to get a solid uh
run for a while there without any
craziness i i don't know like me but
people thought i mean
being in the middle east in itself is a
trauma i mean i was
i didn't want to i mean it definitely is
yeah i mean it's just like you know it
is a trauma you know
on my show i make this joke like
whenever you find a white male shooter
he's crazy it's like wow what the middle
easterners we could be crazy there's a
thousand things in the middle east that
drives us crazy let me give you an
example you guys send your troops
to the middle east they come back with
ptsd we [ __ ] live there
yeah we live there we have the source
code
of craziness we could be crazy
you know so so so uh the the middle east
is just like a big bag of trauma
but we since we've just been living
there all our lives we don't feel it
it's kind of like oh it's like we come
here to the you come here
and americans like are you know are um
complaining of something it's like oh
that's normal i i i made fun when i was
in houston
i went there in the that terrible week
when they had like
shortage of everything and oh you go
down there
yeah i went there i went there like the
day that
uh ted cruz left to cancun i yeah i came
in as a savior from los angeles
so i uh i i
the first thing i said like guys like
this this week this terrible i mean look
at you guys
i mean you had like failing
infrastructures corrupt politicians
absolute lack of human rights like heat
electricity and water americans were
like oh my god that's terrible arabs
were like welcome to our lives [ __ ]
yeah it's kind of like i was like but
this is their apocalypse like
back home that's tuesday so it's kind of
like we're used to a lot of [ __ ]
but i think because we lived through
that
all our lives and through a generational
kind of
acceptance of that's that's what life is
maybe there is trauma but we don't
really realize it's strong yeah but
there's more to you there's the hustle
that i love so much i see where does
that come from where does that work
ethic
that's instilled in you that don't give
up don't like we're gonna go do this now
instead of whoa
is me where is that who does that come
from being a nerd
a nerd you were a nerd growing up
medical school bro
i mean still a doctor's [ __ ] bro
doctor's fault
no but like seriously i think it is it
is
maybe it's the way that we're raised i
mean we're raised not to complain
you get good grades good for you not for
us it's just
it was always expected that you need to
over perform
even to over deliver that is not
something that you should be rewarded to
or being you know
uh to have a pat on the back that just
just
what's what it is it's expected as
expected at the end of the day it's like
i agree and at the end of the day if you
don't do it you're gonna fail you're
gonna survi
you need to survive and i think
i really i always talk to myself saying
that i need
to stop i need to tell my
i need to remind my entitled self
that the world doesn't owe me anything
that's right
it sure as [ __ ] doesn't and i think we
all need to remind our entitled selves
that the world doesn't owe you anything
it's like
oh good okay so you were uprooted you
were investigated or interrogated it
your show was taken boohoo all right
nobody's going to give you a handout you
know i mean i don't know any [ __ ]
comedians that's happened to and then
had to go to another country and start
all over and be a success and as a
matter of fact if you kind of like
cower and and wail that's exactly what
is
but all of these things all of these
people want from you nobody is going to
like all right
come out now it's fine no that's life
so and and if you do it like the people
who hate you they were
i i think i think for a very long time
i was kind of motivated by revenge
and this is the the wrong
this is the wrong motive revenge on who
or what
revenge of all of the people who doubted
me who kind of reveled in my failure
of having everything that's taken away
from me who always kind of like made
sure that like oh you're done your
husband
because that gets to you and
so now when i'm kind of like having a
kind of a
moderate success i feel like even if i
got
the best thing if i want an oscar
tomorrow it doesn't matter the trolls
will always be trolls the haters are not
gonna be haters and then
at the end of the day if you got your
oscars your golden globes your emmys
your specials on netflix your best
sellers your a million dollar deal
who are these people why are they
important for you to take revenge at
them
they're not you i think it's it was
for a very long time i knew this was a
very negative uh impulse
you did know i did know but i couldn't
help it but now when i say i'm much more
relaxed i'm much more
um i'm doing it for myself i'm doing it
to prove to myself that i still exist i
still i'm still relevant i can still
create
i'm happier so um i've always used it
instead of revenge is fuel
you know you two oh you don't thank you
just put it in the tank put it in the
tank put it in the tank
you know and then use it to fuel you
instead of
force you away from something motivation
absolutely yeah so um
yeah so yeah i i think the the the
the if if this is a show about the low
lights
and about the trauma it's always about
kind of
that uncertainty that always had
is i mean it was an uncertainty that
came after like a very very huge success
because the the success was meteoric
it's like three
three years boom you're on top of the
word and then boom it's taken away from
you
and now you have to climb your way up
again
very very you now you have to play with
the rules
that applies for everybody right but
you're doing it
we'll see you're doing it when i do that
when i get my that netflix special
i can i'll tell you um i want to go back
and ask you
um your parents who was the bigger
disciplinarian mom or dad
mom it sounds like mom when you said and
then were your parents still married
when
your mom passed they were did you get
any closer to your father during those
few years where he was still alive yeah
well my dad
is one of those people that you
appreciate them much
later in life my dad was
very or as i thought was passive
he was like you know minding his own
business he also want to have his space
well you said he's a judge though and
i've been in front of my share of judges
and i gotta say of all the people i've
dealt with in my life judges seem to be
right here like it didn't matter what
anyone ever said offensive to him they
would just go
okay yeah that that was yeah i was
amazed by that like
it's you've seen so much and probably
heard so much or desensitized to
the people taking these shots at you to
the point where it just
just bounces right off my dad was that
and because he was quiet and my mom was
the most focused
you had to get attracted you you look at
your mom as the source of authority
you look at your mom she's the judge and
she's the jury yeah
yeah she no she's the judge and the jury
and the executioner
yeah she's all out she's everything but
uh i didn't appreciate my dad until very
much later in life i saw how much of an
incredible dad
an incredible man he he was and he did
everything quietly
he didn't make a fuss about anything in
what ways was he like i mean he was
there he provides he did he was just
like making sure that everything but
it's kind of like because you're a kid
you don't see
it's like you know like like the duck in
the water you don't see her legs
that was not my dad so yeah i mean
parenting is a long game it's a it's a
long
slow play and yeah it doesn't pay reward
if you did if you've done your job
half as good as you hoped to then yeah
your kids might not
realize i look back on my dad had twins
in in 1973 i'm 47 and i
i just you know he's gone now but he was
at every [ __ ] practice
at every game he was in ve i look back
now like
how in the hell did you how did you do
it we worked an
hour from where we live like how the
hell did you do it
and i start to look back on all those
things and you know there's so many
questions i wish i could
ask him now um but
yeah i um i get that i get that
yeah no i mean my mom was like one of
those women who were very
she was very flamboyant she was taurus
she was always there she was
so she needed the gratification you know
appreciation my dad didn't have didn't
need any of that
he was just in his own head
and are you and your brother close yeah
and is he still in egypt
yeah he is yeah is he still an engineer
yes did he ever did he ever want to work
for you do you ever want to come on the
show
my brother was kind of like you know
just kind of like watch from afar uh
and uh yeah we still have we're still
we're still good we say he's a wonderful
brother now you said some of your other
family
turned on you are they still uh
are you still excommunicated from them
or what well half of them are dead have
the other half we don't speak anymore
you don't yeah they don't hit you
up or no that's fine i mean i i i i
think with my parents dying as if the
like the connections were severed
as if there was a sign for me it was
like all right you can go now and you
can go now
yeah so pursue this so los angeles is my
home
united states is my country and i deal
with it as this
way i don't i i try as much as possible
not to let
whatever is back there annoy me so you
do you want to do would you want to do
another show like that
i don't know no i really don't know i
stopped thinking about it a long time
ago i'm focused about what i do now are
you still doing the plant-based show
yeah you still have that going
yeah yeah and yeah plan say it again
plant
bee tv tv yeah okay and um what do you
surprisingly
like what meals do you think are you
wouldn't expect to be good like if i'm
sitting here like
what what would i which what's the first
thing i try be to get me hooked
i can't help you you can't give me one
suggestion no because
you all got a fake chicken parmesan
because because
because here's the thing the whole it
it's a it's a it's a philosophy about
trying to reduce what's bad for you it's
more about like
excluding the stuff that you shouldn't
eat so
uh the thing is it's not an instant
thing
because your taste buds takes time until
they use so for example now when i eat
arugula or spinach
they taste sweet really yeah because
it tastes so long because my my my taste
buds are not blunted anymore by all of
the oil and the salt and the sugar
and all of the the processed stuff so
now i enjoy
kind of much more basic foods and it
tastes much better
okay uh i i i was one of those people
like
i was a typical egyptian with like three
or four spoons of sugar in my tea
oh wow really yeah that's very that's
very very calm very egyptian
wow three four spoons of sugar and your
tea and my tea
daily yeah now i can't even take
put like half a spoon i can't what does
it do to your body
sugar yeah what what doesn't it do to
your body
yeah well obviously if you had a cup of
that right now
oh no i mean you're sick would you i
would i would i would i would
i could i wouldn't even like one simple
just like outs like i can't and
but it's like it's the whole thing about
like it's all comes down to one thing
inflammation
it's the kind of inflammation that these
foods does to you
yeah so so do you have do you have any
children
i have nadia that that the book the
children's book that magical reality
is based on her she's nine she's not and
adam is three and a half
so you have a nine and a three and a
half yeah man you did a little late like
me
i got a six year old yeah i should
[ __ ] go
plant-based because i could probably
move around better
watch the game changes and forks over
knives maybe it's a good start
all right and where are your daughters
now my daughter is
in i think they
they we're in rondo beach so the schools
now are kind of like 50
so they are like in in school 50 and
online 50 okay and are you married
yeah you are you don't wear a ring uh
well i mean we don't wear wearing
because
like we do a very active life and kind
of like it it kind of
uh sushi doesn't wear into we don't we
don't let this stuff like
you know define our nation i hear you
i'm big on that too i believe in that
and these are all like pagan uh rituals
anyway
i love it i wanna learn bro um look i
know we gotta get you out of here
so um i wanna ask you um
after everything we've talked about now
going back to
16 year old you
what would you what advice would you
give to 16 year old boss oh that's easy
buy bitcoin
absolutely man what the hell i would
like be buying bitcoin since like
when it was like six cents do you have
it now no i have nothing
i i i go back and tell you i missed out
i missed out man
[ __ ] buy bitcoin that's it
i love it please uh one more time plug
anything you'd like
thank you well uh i'm going to be in uh
qahoga falls ohio 11 to 13th of march
miami 19th to 21st of march which is my
birthday by the way
and uh by the book it's a children's
book it's a beautiful book
based on nadia and it has magic egyptian
ancient egyptian history
and it's a really cool book and it's one
of it is really
topping the chart now so it's called the
magical reality of an idea and thank you
thank you thank you for coming on this
has been uh really great i appreciate it
thank you so much
um as always ryan sickler.com ryan
sickler on all social media we'll talk
to you all
next week
[Music]
you